es spricht ja nicht grundsätzlich gegen
vielmehr geht es um den unverstellten
ersten mal vielleicht nur die fiktionen
hatten daten informationen auch schon
doch nur neuronen aber das können wir
zu weil das einfach eine falsche
als beispiel zu den digitale währung
paar herausgreifen simulation wird sehr
ihre algorithmen zdh ist geprägt durch
sie sehen hier im hintergrund monitore
dieser vorteil der virtualität
können wir uns wirklich nicht
das virtuelle digitale buch nicht kaputt
bereiche unserer lebenswelt jetzt habe
darüber wie viel information vorliegt
wirklichkeit also und theologisch
noch ein ganz ganz wichtigen zitat hier
jetzt können wir uns aber wirklich
fragen auf denn unser sales bildung an
neutral einfach die tatsache des kreativ
natürlich auch eine form von der
zerfällt also diese diese kreative
die digitalisierung dass wir sie
zuschauer zur aktuellen sitzung über
eine etwas neues möglich ist dann bin
davor durch alle möglichen formen von
blick das genau hinsehen um die
konstruktion und der aushandlung neuer
den begriff infos fähre eingehen der
also er sagt ungefähr so um die
fragen warum sollten wir uns überhaupt
vergleich ist briefe braucht tag bisher
entscheidend wie wir mit den digitalen
bitcoin online gegeben und so weiter das
fiel also von diesem druck den dieses
erscheinen wenn sie mein denken vor 50
tun aber dann verliert eben auch das
realität man könnte sagen
der getrennte entwicklung technischer
ja jetzt muss man aber ehrlicherweise
das ein riesenvorteil
realität also virtuelle realität sagen
häufig genannt
gebrauchen soll nur wenn wir sie falsch
verwenden lässt wenn wir letztere
ethik der digitalität heute geht es zum
ich schon an den begriff gebracht
umgang der bedeutet dass wir uns auf
nachvollziehbare analyse die wirkungen
unsere emotionen rühren wie fühlen wir
medien aber auf der anderen seite sehen
dem medium is the message also das
vorgelegen hat oder hätte vorliegen
medien umgehen sollen ja das ist die
ich darin auch frei kann ich meine
flug idee sehr zentrales infos fähre ist
mentale sein spezifische gehalten wie
automatisierte entscheidungsverfahren
jahren wenn man ihn da erzählt oder vor
jetzt nicht normativ werden zum einfach
weitere möglichkeit des virtuellen sich
nämlich lebenswelt dem werde ich sehr
spielekonsolen glaube das ist eine
noch mal fragen ich glaube die frage
sozialität und umgangsformen sowohl von
art dass die plötzlich und miteinander
jahrtausendwende und vor allem eben auch
heißt am ende der virtualisierung die
illusionen gaukeln uns was vor
sagen dass es virtuelle realitäten schon
nicht echte realität also irgendwie eine
information l auffassen in diesem fall
andere informationen beziehen und zwar
lettern beweglichen lettern druck den
einen anderen kontinent gelandet
gebrauchen wenn wir also nur von
der verlockenden und gleichzeitig
uns inmitten der total verrechnung ums
sollen in immer größerer menge verfügbar
thema begriffliche grundlagen ich gebe
die den informationsüberfluss reduzieren
100 jahren sie können irgendwann
medium ist nicht nur so neutraler boote
kreative fantasie auch im sinne einer
die autoren bestimmt hinzu ist nicht mit
häufig im semester jetzt in diesem
erübrigt sich eigentlich habe ich möchte
wir jetzt dass wir auch mit diesen daten
playstation portable oder eine ist eine
kann ich zum beispiel meine gefühl der
vorzustellen ist das universal lexikon
interferieren interagieren plötzlich
frage eben der medienkompetenz und das
landeten heutzutage kann ich eine e mail
mit dem internet und mit dem
ein neologismus der in den 1970 er ja
vor dem aufkommen der neuen medien wie
auf eine ganz verschiedene weil es auf
wir durch die digitalisierung vollziehen
vielleicht täuschen wir uns auch in die
sie trotzdem noch mal aufklären warum
leben was bedeutet freiheit in
guttenberg durch die bucht entwickelt
spielekonsolen hängen oder nur im
universität seminare von zu hause aus
ließe sich sagen was wirklich ist es
unheimlichen apparate die wir so tief in
macht erstmal verfasst nichts halt sie
hinter der nachricht das medium selbst
seminar benutzen ist er trinkt immer
falsche realität ist es vielleicht nur
bloßer simulation zu verwechseln ihren
langeweile wie kann ich das erklären
ist mit der information sind
kommt alles in bewegung alles wird
das internet gar zum beispiel banken
und formen so dass sich aus den vom
fiktion natürlich ganz stark betätigen
eine individuelle weise dh referenz
noch mal einen kurzen rückblick auf die
wikipedia es hier zu nennen das kann man
lucy ohne illusionen hängen natürlich
sollten wir uns eigentlich philosophisch
allgegenwärtigen das haus wieder diese
nintendo und switche ich weiß es nicht
ist auch ein ganz wichtiges thema eine
menschlichen akteuren
können haben wir gar kein geldschein
permanenter digitaler koexistenz welchen
gleich herumschicken ich kann ein online
als infosphere geprägt wurde er ist dem
sagte tait poker face no tonia
durch neuronale vorgänger ich kann schon
informationen über information
cyberspace unterwegs sind oder nur vor
informationen und was informationelle es
mit seinem komischen
aufeinander bezogen und das sind
unserem alltagsleben integriert haben
zitat wird qualität hat im
auch leben können das heißt wir sind
auch mit fiktionen zusammenhalt und
mit der digitalisierung befassen ist es
letzte sitzung wir hatten den
dehnt sich immer weiter aus und es ist
hat eine botschaft das vermittelt nicht
ethik der digitalität jetzt nicht im
menschen produzierten datenmengen
sich fragen ist wikipedia eine virtuelle
realität ist jetzt nicht nur zu
lebensweltlich aspekt es ist einfach
chef machen oder eine videotelefonie was
und versuchen herkömmliches auf neue
also das virtuelle ist nichts mehr was
hier sehen sie einen playstation
mehr in unsere lebenswelt vor also wir
banknoten sagen viele forscher sind ein
bildschirm verfolgen da sehen sie andere
mehr das heißt wir lösen wie man mir von
technology battisti natural resources
ein schein
natürlich mit der digitalisierung
wert hat folgen auch ein bild welchen
müssen rational beurteilt werden es geht
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert eine
infolgedessen erleben wir eine stetige
unterschied zwischen ethik der
informationen gewinnen lassen die der
dem handy sitzen und das handy nur
controller aber das ist das was wir
ausdruck biosphäre nachgebildet mit dem
ist wirklich in ebendieser entsprechung
sagen da passiert das und das jetzt in
nicht die aufgabe der informatik oder
verstehen im sinne von information zu
überall wir finden es in den
erstmal eine neutrale feststellung und
sinne einer ethik der digitalisierung
eine virtuelle alternativ eine
spannende frage was ist der unterschied
zusammen er spricht davon dass wir es
weise zu realisieren und das scheint mir
nicht nur informationen wir fehlt nicht
digitalität und ethik der
normalisierung in zahlreichen
personen dann hätte man ihnen gesagt das
wert hat musik ist der mensch überhaupt
eine künstlichkeit ein künstliches leben
können fast nicht mehr einen bereich
auch immer das heißt
nur botschaften sondern selbst eine
zwischen illusion und fiktionen ich
den physischen grundlagen von dem papier
betrachten dann treten diese probleme
bedeutet dass wir uns zurückziehen eine
der informationswissenschaft
also nicht primär darum etwas wie das
meinem gehirn aber ist das dasselbe wie
dann müssen wir philosophin und
typischer fall von virtueller realität
menschlichen wahrnehmung zugänglich sind
zunahme der verantwortlichkeit der
einer digitalen medien kompetenz die
damit assoziieren das digitale wird
dem sinne bisherigen was mit der
digitalisierung betrachtet und dazu
wir jenen beschränkt bereich aus unserem
einer kohärenten kultur der digitalität
virtualisierung des herkömmlichen
die räumlichen und zeitlichen grenzen
table like-button ort im radio and like
ist ja alles schön gut aber das ist ein
noch der subjekte geschichte oder wohnt
nur informationen vor sind wir tun auch
gerade der witz von virtuelle realität
gesellschaftlichen bereichen erfahren
botschaft
liegt die wurzel einige der
identifizieren und zur lebenswelt der
philosophen die sache betrachten und
auf vielleicht ja auch nicht man kann
warum geldscheine besitzen ihren wert
und zu grundlagen des singulären und
dieses gefühl der langweilig glaube
antwort können sie sich schon denken die
von dem was bei anfassen können und das
akteure je mehr ein stück informationen
fragt wie viel stunden sollten wir am
rauchende die smartphone sucht als
glaube der unterschied ist der
scheinwelt sondern gegenteil virtuelle
planeten bezeichnen wo leben möglich ist
universal lexikons wie etwa der kork aus
bereich der fiktion
information gemacht wird oder was sich
war das virtuelle noch bis zum ende des
der technologischen entwicklung nur noch
finden uns über unsere digitalen
läuft eben auch im sinne des bloß
und das sagte das ist bei allen neuen
nicht
die verschwinden also alles rückt
infektionen wissen wir dass es nur eine
was mit der information nur die
hatte ich ein paar bücher vorgestellt
zu sein und auch der witz der
mich durch digital ist irgendwie
fragen ja was bedeutet das jetzt
tiefgreifendsten wandlungen und
nämlich auch daran denken dass durch die
tag vor dem computer sitzen damit es
dass wir es damit zu tun haben also
schlecht darzustellen das wäre zu
reduzieren wir das phänomen es geht am
gemeinschaftlichen handelns werden
ganze wird immer mehr verflüchtigt sage
es wird aber auch häufig mit fake in
nur einen bequemen klick weit entfernt
genauso vor 300 jahren wenn man dachte
digitalisierung ist schon längst nicht
mich aufgrund der materiellen basis den
endgerät das internet wird immer
zwischen informationen abspielt und so
any state shapes not only privat
einmal dieses recht klamm küchlein über
der begriff der info sphäre entwickelt
realitäten können verschiedene neue
information tut fast wie auch immer und
der irgendwie 15 bände umfasst und drei
substanziell bei können wir beim
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts von
moralphilosoph moralisch ist das jetzt
digitalität zu sein und wenn das so ist
vielmehr um für idi hat diese neue
einfach keine verteufelung der unsere
schwierigsten probleme die im
digitalisierung nicht nur unsere
können angesichts der von menschen und
noch gesund ist sind die er wie sollen
nicht kulturen digitale kultur um seine
ist desto weniger wird uns nachgesehen
formen der fall von neun mädchen gibt es
spielerischen oder auch süchtig
mehr nur interesse für die informatik
präsenter mit der technischen
ich jetzt mal digital nämlich zum
fiktion ist in illusionen nicht in die
betroffen ist oder vielleicht sogar auch
euphorischen des apokalyptischen
ende verloren wenn wir es
man fliegt auf den mond wie auch immer
sich schnell gefasst inhalt er die
betrunkenen papier sondern aufgrund
zusammenhang mit der technologie
verbindung punkt also es nur ein ja eine
moralisch bedenklich ist das moralisch
anwender der massen programme nur vom
digitale ethik leben in vernetzten
da kommt doch noch mal eine neue
verfehlt ist ganz hilfreich weil wir als
entwicklung und dadurch sagt stade hat
dann müssen natürlich ganz neue ethische
gebende technik und keine ängstlichen
gesundheit geschädigt wird sind das die
maschinen generierten riesigen
beispiel auf eine bank account
sensations-bronze patterns of community
aber diese neuen digitalen möglichkeiten
räumliche und zeitliche logik im sinne
formen von gemeinschaftlichkeit von
regal meter bei ihm einen und sehr
sondern betrifft uns alle wenn sie
durch sie transformiert wird
reaktionen um den menschen im cyberspace
illusion vertauschen wir die realität
werden wenn wir ihm nicht nachgehen dass
demnächst auf uns zukommen werden tja
milieus selbe personal social
machenden verstanden hier ist also ein
dimension endspiel eine dynamische
wir durch das digitale hindurch so
kulturelle entwicklung der
datenmengen wären wir ohne algorithmen
gesamte informationelle umwelt die von
einer inter subjektive gesellschaften
welten und dieses buch von sarah
natürlich haben wir dann immer noch den
eine trug ein vielleicht ein betrug
nutzerinnen und nutzer jetzt wird's
gut oder auf was müssen wir achten oder
transformation ist auch so ein schöner
schreiben ähnlich scheint es mehr sich
schutzhaltung werden empfohlen sind eine
digitalisierung im sinne der
die erlauben uns leben fiktionen zur
individuum sprechen das entspannende
schwer ist immer wieder verstaubt und
digitalisierung dazu kommen wir noch
kommunikation und interaktion bedeuten
lebensverändernde techniken geworden
dimension die mir durch die bloße
der reibungslose kite beschrieben also
mit der realität und die realität mit
konsequentes auf annie medien das ist
fragestellungen auch auf diese form von
begleitet hat es inzwischen eingang
nicht auch ins zentrum rücken und nicht
chaos das ganze fliegt auseinander
spiekermann über digitale ethik die ein
computer den wir anfassen können um die
begriff der gerne gebraucht wird in der
virtualisierung ist auch erlaubt unsere
independence also
sämtlichen informationellen entitäten
zu verhalten mit dem virtuellen auch das
ist wirklich alles was
wie ändern sich auch unsere
die kt
fundierte kritischen haltung erst im
fragen wie sieht es aus mit unserer
handeln dass wir kompetent handeln und
vielleicht das problematisch sind der in
nimmt all das ist ganz wichtig
hatte ich schon erwähnt diese drei
die ihren wert für birgt
genauer also künstliche intelligenz des
sogar
eine super leitfähigkeit sagt friede
mehr nur die information vor der wir
realität werden zu lassen das heißt hier
der realität da verstehen wir nicht dass
sind die digitalisierung dann sollten
informations und
fokussierung auf die information noch
virtuelle realität werfen weil wir da
auf annie extensions aus herbst result
zahlreiche standardisierte praktik
typographie der buchdruck ist nicht nur
ihren eigenschaften interaktionen
und diese
handlungsfeldern sich dadurch in unserem
bereiche referenziert algorithmen zieht
wertesystem für das einundzwanzigste
gesundheit entgegenzukommen indem wir
individualität
wirtschaft eine ökonomie spricht man da
einigen jahren vereint der eigentlich
das liegt uns um die ohren vor allem
maus mit der wir uns dann auf dieses
virtuelle realität eröffnet abseits der
wirklich ist ist information l alles was
kommunikationstechnologie sorgen dafür
zuge einer tiefen auseinandersetzung
internet vielleicht sogar auch
können wir nicht einfach nur im sinne
verschwinden
ich möchte nur ein bisschen kritisieren
wird die grenze zwischen fiktion und
jahrhundert entwickeln möchte es gibt
was tun wie entwickeln da möglichkeiten
eben unsere freiheit vergrössern und
nicht mehr nur die informatikerinnen die
nicht angemessen berücksichtigt zu
also normalerweise hat ein geldschein
es sich nicht um realität handelt
brillen werden auch häufig genannt 3d
herrscht in der digitalen infos wäre
dass jetzt
nach seinem buch bereits vor alt ist und
prozessen und wechselbeziehungen
handeln wenn die digitalisierung immer
gefallen also das virtuelle wird immer
häufiger von auch auf eine dysfunktion
computerspiele die formen eine
zum beispiel apps entwickeln denn
of the new school der des interviews
dass die menschen moralisch eine immer
lässt sich eine selbstbewusste
gemeinschaftlichkeit status auch ein
und gemeinschaftlichkeit das beschreibt
eine technologie sind selbst eine
informatiker darüber was zu sagen haben
realität fließen durch die
flucht möglichkeit in eine totale und
unseren kindern die eben nur noch
des physikalischen beschreiben das
digitalisierung bedeutet eben nicht nur
gebildet wird es ist dies eine umwelt
weiter in unsere lebenswelt ein drink
werden scheint das heißt wir müssen
information l ist wirklich ich habe das
eigentlich gar kein wert oder ganz
also die dicht digitale technologie die
einschätzung vornehmen die uns als
weil es einfach keine räumlichen und
stalder sagt dass algorithmen zieht
weiter die es bislang so noch nicht gab
größere verantwortung tragen für den
mehr wie auch das digitale teil unserer
brille also man hat irgendwie so ein
er jetzt folgendermaßen referenziert ist
schon verschiedene ansätze über die
gerade nicht in so ein schwarzes loch
illusion ist noch ein ganz spezifischer
konto selbst ist nichts mehr was wir
smartphones die uns immer wieder daran
sondern eben alle die es betrifft eben
interface bei extensions auswärts bei
virtualisierung
wichtiger aspekt dass es eine zweite
einheitliche kultur und stellen nicht
bei wikipedia ist es so nicht gibt er
computerspiel dazu ein geläufiges
immer fragen was tun wir auch mit diesen
möglicherweise totalitäre alte reed also
natürliche ressourcen wie baumwolle und
virtuelle ist auch nicht eigene form von
menschen und als gesellschaft
zeitlichen reibung mehr gibt die
geringen wert das wird ein 100 euro
wir sehen das durch künstliche
deswegen ist die virtuelle realität ein
die ein vergleich mit dem cyberspace
ethik der digitalisierung hier ist dann
die verrechnung unseres lebens das wäre
lebens etwas zu was ganz normale und
erinnern dass wir jetzt das und das tun
wirklich in der hand haben können wie
zustand in dem sich die welt befindet
pfeiffer sich das ist also ein vorschlag
eigenschaft die diese prozesse der
und dann stellen sich vielleicht neue
nur so separate voneinander getrennte
ein bisschen meine zweifel weil ich
information die fliesen einfach so
eingezogen werden das heißt sie sollen
ist ein eigenes phänomen das auch sein
auch die philosophie
scheins einen materiellen wert haben
die nutzung bestehenden kulturellen
modul vor augen und da wird an irgend
intelligenz durch assistenten digitale
realität und dagegen kann man die
ganzen daten und da wird dann die ethik
weiterbringt ich glaube dem ist nicht zu
erlaubt sich jedoch insofern von dem
vorurteil und eine geläufige kritik dann
etwas anderes und das andere an
ein geldschein
uns hilft uns zu orientieren
soll sowie die uns motivieren bestimmte
kreatives phänomen hier werden wir
einem new technologies neue medien sind
zur klassifizierung der rede über
ethische fragen
glaube dass unsere handlungen unsere
befinden wird oder befinden sollte das
wie autonom und bündig mit diesen neuen
nichts mehr zu was nur spekulativen das
der hat ein buch geschrieben die 50
digital eben mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
materials für die eigene produktion
digitalität kennzeichnet nur über ein
kulturen da drin under nichts zu tun
die idee der digitalisierung verstanden
realität abgrenzen auch wenn die surreal
sprechen dennoch glaube ich dass
die perspektive einer bloßen
ethisches problem er hat darauf hört man
produktionszweige ganze produkt zweige
das heißt virtuelle realität bedeutet
der digitalität besonders zentral
holz und alles mögliche also es ist eine
schätze mal vielleicht ein euro ich weiß
unterscheidet als diese gewissermaßen
jetzt möchte ich als nächsten begriff
etwas vorgegaukelt vielleicht brauchen
wirklich die unsere fantasie unserer
gesehen dass durch smartphones
scheinwelt einen eigenen raum
übungen zu machen oder die unsere
virtuelle realität wenn wir jetzt über
oder annähernd lichtgeschwindigkeit
erweiterungen und zwar selbst wie auch
auch ein wirklich spannender titel
diesen überschaubaren
haben und dann spricht er von einer
auch noch mal eingehen separat ja und
handlungs vollzug auch mit und durch die
als technik philosophie also als
kollektiv getragen referenzrahmen können
medien im sinne der virtuellen realität
vielleicht auch bald durch integrierung
wichtigsten dinge der digitalisierung
nur ein ihr und an ihrer unterbereiche
ist ein bisschen paradox weil die ekd
durch die datenleitung und jetzt sagt er
das war jetzt in kurzer rückblick und
verändern dass die kundinnen und kunden
das post digitale immer schon überholt
es nicht genau jedenfalls nicht 100 euro
kreativität
den begriff der information ins zentrum
virtuelle ist also nicht länger ein
gar nicht ist wir haben es mit fiktionen
also ist nicht so positiv durchaus auch
eine andere realisierungsphase
verhandlung für erfindungen für
eine zentrale eigenschaft ist es viele
selber krank wie die die das
schritte zählen und uns dann belohnen
angewandte philosophie oder auch als
digitalität reden dann halten wir uns
immer das zu verstehen ist wollen wir
herausgefordert hier können wir selbst
interagieren das ist die eigentliche
digitale thale strukturen in unserem
sehr lesenswertes buch informativ über
enormen vervielfältigung der kulturellen
technischer sicht nur 0 und einzelne
auch teil eines umfassenden und phänomen
eigentliche materielle basis nur medien
dann möchte ich auch noch auf das
mengen von daten
jetzt wollen wir aber hier auf die
plötzlich ganz neue wünsche haben neue
der wert des geldscheins der kommt
neuen medien mehr ist als nur
modell für einen technischen eskapismus
darstellt da die info sphäre außerdem
handhabung von gegenständen für
bereits bestehende phänomen ja wir haben
bedeutung stabilisiert handlungsdruck
stellen luciano florida hatte ich schon
phänomen youtube hinweisen viel lokales
zu tun natürlich sind fiktionen
dann noch genauer erklären gerade auch
usw das heißt ich glaube es kommt immer
folgen daraus einige ethische probleme
bereichs die digitalisierung wird nach
sehr experimentell interagieren meine
digitalisierte leben unsere gesundheit
verfahren mit denen sich menschen in
immer hier auch in der realität auf
sind dass die eindeutige zuschreibung
sie strukturieren und zu handeln vor sie
möglichkeiten die mit der
digitalisierung bedeutet wie ich
alle möglichen bereiche der sagt der
ist das digitale überholt das post
körper
begrifflich nicht realität und während
frage der medienkompetenz
aus der lebenswelt sind sie eröffnet
dadurch zustande dass wir uns auf ein
mit blick auf die digitalisierung wie es
den offline und den analogen
fingerfertigkeiten für interaktionen ist
heutige sitzung genau eingehend wo wir
angebote bekommt digitale produkte also
erwähnt er hat ein buch geschrieben die
information das ist eine these die ich
zurück generiert und ressourcen
nur auf den gebrauch dieser neuen medien
besetzt virtuelle realität es ist
implementierung ich will jetzt nicht so
kulturelle prozesse ein schreiben im
digitalisierung einhergehen wir sind
fernsehen also man könnte die these
einer digitalen ethik oder redet der
jedes sagte erleben wir eine
sind selbst materielle realitäten die
es gesehen banknote wird zur online
virtuelle realität ist eine form der
versucht habe vor und zeigen auch die
fortschritt der digitalisierung wird uns
ruiniert natürlich wenn die lebenswelt
sehr komplexer inter- subjektive art
der verantwortung an bestimmte handelnde
erweiterung unserer selbst im sinne zb
these ist dass die virtuelle realität
digitale waren es scheint mir momentan
informationsraum mit um greift also
vierte revolution wie die info sphäre
irgendwas was uns nicht ganz geheuer ist
er keine fiktion sind
substanzielle ausfüllung des rechts auf
weit gehen jetzt hier gleich von cyborg
das sozial wie auch ökonomischen
zugänglich gemacht werden dabei
erlaubt es uns überhaupt erst zu handeln
eine kaum überschaubare fülle von
digitalisierung verstanden im sinne
jetzt diese formen der kultur der
hier wird auch wieder davon gesprochen
uns mit begrifflichen grundlagen
an die neuen medien als solche sind wir
realität die aber natürlich immer bezug
währung oder online guthaben
kontext eine nicht zu überblickenden
vertreten youtube ist eine virtuelle
virtualisierung also die neuen
zeitnah mit der wohl größten
gerade in der wirtschaft sehen wir dass
eine ökologie der freiheit bedeutet was
noch ein bisschen weiter mit ihm
unsere wirklichkeit nicht nur dadurch
immer digitaler wird dann müssen uns
person schwieriger und zweifelhafter
prognosen sind wünsche sind
darauf geeinigt haben dass er 100 euro
digitalität dagegen auch noch näher ein
entstehen gemeinschaftliche formationen
austausch ja das ist jetzt die
befassen wollen die wir hier erklären
dass die umfassende implementierung der
zu reden aber so kleinere
zumindest da keine perspektive jenseits
szenarien des einstiegs im bundes
der referenz sanität oder
eines bereichs unserer lebenswelt der
diskutieren möchte ich glaube das ist
infos fähre ist kurz gesagt die gesamte
und was mit der wirklichen realität mit
unser leben verändert und auch hier
zivilisatorischen herausforderung
möglichkeiten die da entstehen unsere
nichtwissen in einer immer reibungslos
erstmal neutral die können sich in die
das ist ganz wichtig dass wir hier schon
virtualisiert das universität seminar
hat zur realität zur fiktion zur
realität eine virtualisierung des
müssen bevor wir auf eine ethik der
fragen tut uns das auch gut eben auch
die digitalisierung unglaublich viel
implementierung in brillen vielleicht
verändern dass sie irgendwie
ganz wichtig ist uns selbst oder unsere
gemeinschaftlichkeit fluide neu bedeutet
macht das wäre zum beispiel ein
eine oder die andere richtung aus wirkt
referenz realität
konfrontieren die es je zu bewältigen
die selbstbezogenen welten hervorbringen
projektierungen auch fantasie produkte
wert sein soll dazu kommen natürlich
ist damit gemeint
freiheit in kreativen sind wir
digitalen maschinen eine neue bedingung
offenen bezugspunkten werden auswählen
möchte ich eine zentrale zitat vorlesen
der digitalisierung gibt die mich auch
perspektive vor allem aus der ökonomie
informationen zum beispiel vermitteln
diese algorithmen also künstliche
der echten eine spannung tritt so wird
anschluss an diese virtualität ist teil
meine these ist dass wir durch die
menge der gesamtbereich aller
herkömmlichen fernsehens weil es ganz
funktionierenden infos fähre verliert
verändert und das erlaubt geben die
was wir gerade haben wird nicht mehr in
auch in dem netz so weiter das ist alles
vergrößern
gemeinschaftlichkeit und algorithmen
digitalität mehr eingehen also zum einen
bekommt ja noch ein weiteres zitat aus
die unterschiedliche dimensionen die
spannendes thema für eine hausarbeit wie
handlung als etwas zu verstehen dass
ob das der fall ist und eine frage aber
aus medizinischer hinsicht
simulation und auch zur illusion ganz
sagt dieses buch handelt von den
sondern sie vermitteln auch ein
also aus der wirtschaftlichen
aber diese neue medien kritik ist
wiederum digitalisiert werden könnte
unseres daseins sorgt sie wirft konkrete
virtuelle realität unsere freiheit für
die eben noch nicht vielleicht auch
intelligenz ozean stich werden dass wir
bezeichnung bis funktion ganze alte
gewisse institutionen wie eine
das heißt digitalität so jetzt meine
und zusammenführen zur basalen akten der
nicht mehr verraten erfasst werden kann
die behauptung man habe nichts gewusst
existenz von ästhetischen präferenzen
durchaus denkbar das ist auch im sinne
und zum schluss die smartphone epidemie
virtuelle realität gemeinhin verstanden
sich bringt also zum beispiel
zentrales gibt jetzt sogar auch
zieht das finde ich finde ich sehr
perspektive sehen wir noch viel stärker
unserer lebens will und das in der fülle
rom räumlichen bördner wörtern an den
die digitalität während digitalisierung
klar dieser bezug ist immer gegeben und
hier schon etwas automatisiert
verändern diese informations und
die digitalisierung wird uns jedenfalls
auswirkungen die unsere digitalen ik t
zentralbank wie gewisse symbole wie
materialen gehalt sie haben selbst eine
größer und zwar in unserer gesamten
niemals realität werden könnte darin
flori dieses buch die vierte revolution
studierte von dem post digitalen dass
ja und dann gibt es auch ganz
dieser erweiterung der digitalisierung
sinnvoll dass er da drei solche formen
bedeutungs produktion und selbst
industriezweige brechen ab neue treten
angesichts vergleicht vorhersehbaren
these ist mehr als nur die summe der
darum weil wir wenn wir uns als
und das liegt eben auch die verwendung
und viel mehr dass die digitalisierung
bis hin zu methoden der biologischen
da habe ich schon ein bisschen was dazu
diese bezüge müssen wir immer aufs neue
sehr stark betreffen sie wird vor keinem
sieht digital virtuelle das ist eine
auch der medien interaktion ermöglicht
gefahren für gesundheit bildung und
einbeziehen was wir selbst nicht mehr
anderen universitäten
aller möglichen bezüglich
eigentliche essenz doch ein anderes buch
lebens hält also nicht nur in bestimmten
kommunikationstechnologien diesen neuen
neuen medien mehr als nur smartphones
zu verstehen jetzt glaube ich eben dass
er sagt die neuen medien sind umwelt
ausgemacht hat und wir wollen jetzt mal
besteht aber gerade ihre realität
informations und
information auffassen letztendlich
gesagt dann ein ganz wichtiger begriff
dieser wie april nahe wir haben da eine
logos die auf dem schein darauf die
computer aufklappen und wenn wir uns ins
ereignissen und kaum ignoriert fakten
vollzogen sondern es wird irgendwie raum
konstitution ja das ist jetzt immer noch
versuchen zu klären
dramatische
reproduktionen rhythmen von raum und
man also hier sich auf einem fließband
an ihrer stelle ganz neue
medien wie verändern sie unsere
gesamte informationsraum spannend finde
von ihr in jedem fall aktiv steuern
bereichen wie es die digitale ethik oder
bereich wirklich haltbar
kommunikationstechnologien darauf haben
und monitore und ich weiß nicht was die
gesellschaft ganz interessant ist jetzt
objektivieren das endlose
wir werden bei youtube nicht mehr nur zu
genauer schauen was darunter zu
von marsh & mclennan mit dem titel
uns ganz neue möglichkeiten im sinne der
sehr abstrakt was meint jetzt steigern
gestaltende anthropologische soziale und
rahmenbedingungen werden geschaffen
der unterschied zwischen virtualität
assoziationen wie in diesem buch die
internet begeben da fangen die ethischen
garantieren dass alles das sind ganz
zeit modulieren ihnen wirken in ihnen
befindet und alena unterstützen ein
der begriff der digitalität angemessener
verantwortlichkeit und wie verändern
ja das heißt erst wenn wir den begriff
brille und die simuliert und was die
zunehmend an glaubwürdigkeit
los realisiert nämlich über ein
verstehen ist
wie wir uns selbst verstehen wie wir
auch allen technischen revolution
rezipient innen und rezipienten wie im
jetzt kann man sich aber angesichts
das erleichtert uns oder das ist
die philosophie der digitalisierung tut
understanding media extensions auf mehr
virtuelle realität und simulation
bei allen drei titeln das hier jeweils
offizielle strukturen institutionen aber
ich jetzt dass er hier auch von
damit genau er meint dass wir mit dieser
virtuelle realität wird das nicht wenn
totale computerisierung entwickelt schon
wir müssen allerdings davor noch eine
und ja so wie es in der wirtschaft ist
datengrundlagen nullen und einsen
sich auch unser handeln das ist also
es ist nichts was mit der lebenswelt
simulationen sind ja begrifflich eben
probleme schon an
abgrund und auch dieser autor peter
haut uns was vor der begegnung uns in
virtuelles digitales seminar zum
interpret aktive kräftig war sie
informationen und interaktionen spricht
unterliegen die sich verändern es ist
dieser
der virtuellen realität mit blick auf
miteinander in beziehung treten und wie
wirken dynamiken dem netzwerk macht die
ist und diese diese
sie auf neue weise produkte generieren
volk in form des fernsehens so werden zu
überhaupt die basis dafür dass wir
zweitens kommt es zu einer
vielleicht auch hier stellt sich dann
sondern in allen möglichen bereichen
auf
digitale ethik oder ethische
massiven also dieser überall
als er sagt die medien sind
seit jahren einen mahlstrom artige
beispiel so wo wir uns in einem
illusionen in simulationen haben mit der
schmidt schreibt der leiter des service
ganz wichtige differenz nachvollziehen
die begriffe der möglichkeit der
mehr als die summe
krankheit bezug genommen hat einmal das
nichts zu tun hat sind es erweitert die
wir unsere welt gestalten und mit ihr
schaffen und prägen unsere geistige und
auch keine realitäten weil sie nur
angesichts der informationsflut im
information hatte ich schon angesprochen
auch institutionen wie zb starten oder
so ist es eben auch in unserer ganzen
freiwilligkeit und zwang autonomie und
er spricht aber eher den interaktionen
exponentiellen zunahme an gemein sondern
die frage wie steht es mit uns für
eine ganz ganz spannende frage die eben
digitalisierung ist aber insofern eine
unwirklichen kaum zu überblickenden
pervasive also diese ausdehnende diese
dynamik sie ist aber mittlerweile so
können wenn sie überhaupt neue produkte
vitalität ist mehr als einen rein
virtuellen raum befinden und am ende
wirklichkeit der fiktion der simulation
das erlaubt ebene von einer und
wirklichen realität hat das nichts zu
eindringenden
einmal die differenz zwischen analog und
interagieren
erweiterungen des menschen noch ein
akteuren akteuren in dem wir selbst
materielle wirklichkeit verändern unser
sind wichtiger begriff aber auch die
packs der stanford universität stellte
internet handeln können ja also das ist
lebenswelt nicht nur der wirtschaft alle
freiheit steht es auch um unsere würde
simulieren sie heißt sie bilden die
wissen dies ist einfach terminus aus der
tun das ist so die geläufige auffassung
dimension und natur der neuen medien
lebenswelt im sinne unserer freiheit wir
virtuelle produkte generieren könnte das
einer sitzung über das virtuelle
angewandte philosophie oder ein bereich
masse also das sind zum beispiel
digitale wird im sinne der demenz
unnachgiebig wie ein schwarzes loch
fremdbestimmung in neuer weise
wie
nanotechnologie das internet der dinge
technologisch phänomen mehr als null und
theologie zu sprechen also von einer
illusion geklärt haben können wir
totalitäre auch kurz im negativen sinne
die die informationellen entitäten also
in dieser spannung bisher sehr treffend
universitäten die existieren nur
digital das würde ich die technische
und wie steht es auch mit der bedeutung
info sphäre also der bereich der
selbstverständnis
zitat ist ein medium das shakes &
möglichen bereiche werden verändert ich
informationen im internet finden dass
animiert werden eigene sendungen zu
sitzt uns denn an den existenz wahnsinn
lehre von dem sein weil alles was uns
kürzlich folgende prognose wird wieder
whiteboard gemeinsam interagieren können
weil nach dieser auffassung die
auch sorgen machen und sagen wenn die
realität in manchen gesichtspunkten ab
web 2.0
eins sein digitalität ist eine neue form
logik mit dem allgemeinen verzeichnet
und ich persönlich bin der meinung dass
assoziiert
bekommen ganz neue möglichkeiten damit
dimensionen der digitalisierung zu
sicherlich ganz wichtig diese drei
wirklich fundierte aussage beim edith
auch im rahmen einer hausarbeit oder
virtuell also die existieren jetzt nicht
unseres handelns lahr und zu handeln hat
oder technologische seite nennen also
die die informationen selbst und
finanziell sehr sichtbar und die ethik
control scale in form of human
information der durch die
semantisches web cloud computing
wir mit dieser masse an informationen
ins netz im moment to be passt digital
glaube ich weil die digitalisierung
betrifft irgendwie digitalisiert oder
bezug treten um uns auf uns selbst
dann wird der cyberspace vielleicht auch
kategorien um gemeinschaftlichkeit
aber eben nur in manchen also sie
mit bücherei die sie traditionellerweise
einführt dagegen die die uns nicht
bezeichnen digitalität ist der begriff
produzieren
digitalisierung nur ein teil unserer
digitalisierung so fast schon
wenn wir es mit informationen zu tun
vielleicht auch in einem ass behandelt
der digitalität treffen ich habe jetzt
werden in denen alle nicht nur wissen
digitalisierung natürlich extrem
einander vollziehen also informationen
irgendwie physischen hat die universität
association action der content or use of
der lebenswelt sind der virtuellen
selbst kreativ umgehen können ganz
und indem wir animiert werden kommentare
wir virtueller virtuelle realität
die folgt dann immer erst recht nicht
beziehen und sie bringen unsere
das ist das was einfach bei der
einfach ein phänomen ist es noch
computerspiele mit bewegungserfassung
mehr bedeutung auch im virtuellen raum
entscheiden können ist das wirklich so
analysieren sie
werden könnte jetzt möchte ich als
übergriffig ist und in alle bereiche
finden wo auch an der universität bücher
imaging 2009 die
algorithmen sieht und referenziert um
erweitert und auch der ist ganz wichtig
lebenswelt ausmacht eben wenn wir den
auch virtualisiert werden kann ob es
hier noch ein paar andere begriffe
haben das hängt ganz eng mit der
so florida können auch miteinander
der in meinen augen besser passt für die
digitalisierung im technischen sinne
weltdeutung auf einen neuen besseren
extremer als das der elektrifizierung
durchaus positiver sehen sollten jetzt
virtuellen realität und virtualität
eingebracht möglichkeit und wirklichkeit
dass p also dass irgendetwas der fälle
realität
nach langer zeit weil sie erst
zu verfassen
konstanz die existiert es nicht nur weil
als eine krankheit
bauen das nach aber um und erziehung
als nur 0 und 1 und das ist eine
the
interagieren finde ich spannend mir
der begriff der medien oder genauer
nächstes auf den begriff des mediums
vordringen ob wir es wollen oder nicht
referenz walid zusammen dann haben wir
unter videos in dem wir animiert werden
wichtig ist unlogisch was immer
um die ethik der digitalität zu
smartphone-apps tablet-computer und
computer anschalten oder wenn wir uns
die neueren entwicklungen die
stehen im regal das kann man auch
bezeichnet es gibt eine cyber krankheit
universe sdr factual im shaping the form
stand und all das tun sie eben zu
voraussetzt dass solche neuen produkte
informationen teilen der zum beispiel
jetzt nicht mehr in einer losen
wirklich alles ist darüber müssen wir
warum gut die illusion oder die fiktion
lebenswelt der digitalisierung als nur
sind außerdem jeder weiß dass alle
der gebäude stehen sondern sie hat eine
nicht unbedingt im sinne von
noch ein bisschen näher eingehen also
sie zu lenken und zu verteilen also es
gesagt dem neuen medien ist ganz zentral
wenn das einfach so ein unaufhaltsamer
problematische situation wenn wir alles
touchscreens gps augmented reality
verstehen müssen wir die app ist
es ihnen zeigen der digitalität nicht
verschiedene bereiche neu modellieren
andere aspekt simulationen sind mir
stellt sich jetzt die frage wo beziehen
mobile von israel aus der des behälters
noch reden aber jedenfalls sehr viel und
lebensweltlich entwicklung der
simulation oder spekulation verstehen
kontinuierlich ist denken sie an wenn
solche neuen handlungsformat appelliert
auf facebook per twitter es gibt oder
tiefgreifend wie umfassend und
verfassungs härte gewisse mitglieder sie
medialität digitalität ich beziehe mich
virtualisieren nämlich seine virtuellen
auf informationen reduziert also hier
technologischen als die
digitalisierung im sinne eines bereichs
prozess ist ob es ist müssen wir uns
die hat es natürlich immer mit
wissen dass jeder weiß dass p denken sie
mehr allein dazu sind alles was wir zum
wurden wie sie dann überhaupt auch mal
und auch der begriff der neuen medien
werte auch wenn sie realitäten sehr nahe
und dann sind smartphones epidemisch
wird alles viel name schon interaktiver
lässt nun realisieren lässt nicht nur
digitalisierung verstehen zu koennen
sondern als eine form von realität die
wir menschen mehr nutzerinnen und nutzer
künstliche begleiter unbemannte drohnen
of association
erkenntnistheoretischen und die unter
jetzt können wir eben hier uns eine
spekulativen simulationen oder
seminar to smoke ist jetzt unser
möglichkeiten zu tun ja also wenn wir
unablässig also hier bietet die
bücher weil du sie virtuell sich
jetzt sehen wir aber seit einiger zeit
hat studierende das gehört alles dazu
über whatsapp also ganze neue
auch noch fragen aber ausgesetzt er ist
scheint so ein bisschen
es gibt aber auch andere ansätze habe
ab und zu auf diesen kanadischen
auf die idee kommt darauf zu
durch die virtualisierung
simulieren lässt und das bedeutet eben
übersicht mal anschauen die habe ich
musik die wir hören
beispiel im internet tun hängt
logischen die metaphysischen die
reduktionistischen ansatz im hintergrund
das medium selbst das formt auch unsere
kritik also die neuen medien werden
kommen können das ist aber auch gerade
der neuen medien ihren ort außerhalb
jetzt möchte ich auf den nächsten
man kann sich all das virtuelle nicht
die optionen werfen fantasien entwickeln
lebensweltliche bedeutung der
reflektieren der virtuelle produkte sind
digitale bücher ausleihen und auch
an ein freundeskreis in dem
es dann müssen wir uns dazu kritisch
industriezweige haben sich jetzt damit
eben nicht mehr nur als
ich in der letzten sitzung gezeigt es
fahrerlose autos werde bulls 3d drucker
spektakulären
felix stalder auf dem wir noch zu
vorgeschlagen wir können darüber
also wie viren vielleicht sogar wie
und das digitale was immer eben jetzt
prinzipiell mit anderen zusammen es ist
dass die gesamte lebenswelt betroffen
kulturwissenschaftler marshall mcluhan
begriff einge nämlich virtuelle realität
handygebrauch unser smartphone gebraucht
digitalisierung nicht mehr nur ein
informationen über ein soziales medium
der witz der simulation da sie nicht
ja das heißt wir müssen so glaube ich
diskutieren wir haben die realität die
realitätsverweigerung oder
gck lions
zu stehen wir müssen natürlich noch
gibt den versuch die digitalisierung
nicht nur positiv rezipiert sondern auch
beschäftigt wie wir dies informationen
zum beispiel digitale produkte e books
sprechen kommt setzt diese zeit mit dem
mehr nur rein im sinne des physischen
corona viren zu verstehen
realitätsbezogenen grundlagen der
dann lösen wir uns von der wirklichkeit
ist und nicht nur ein bereich und man
verhalten und jetzt gibt es eben eine
bloße information
und sie sehen an diesem cover schon ist
bereich eine bereichs geht würde der
nur sehr selten möglich im internet
virtuell wieder zurückgeben aber eben
realität ist weil wir damit auch
genau uns mit flori die ästhetik der
zum beispiel 0 und einzeln
realitätsflucht zu verstehen dass auch
was assoziieren sie mit virtueller
handlungen das greift über es ist nicht
viel banaler also im sinne von
geteilt werden also es gibt eine ganz
ist er wirklich dasselbe wie rauchen ist
über den gifte informationen zu
identitätsdiebstahl onlinekurse soziale
jahr 2000 an ich bin der meinung ist es
vorstellen zumindestens irgendwie mehr
und so glauben einigen andere
digitalität klären und der
denn wir scheinen doch mehr zu sein als
wirklich ganz individualistisch zu
kann ja auch sagen es betrifft die und
kann physikalisch sein also irgendwie
die wir im internet finden und zwar
kritik der neuen medien oder eine neue
kritisiert durchaus zu recht manchmal
ist eine möglichkeit auch produkte die
information befassen
nicht physisch dann müssen sie keinen
experimentieren können im geschützten
ist nicht das neueste buch er hat ein
separat getrennt werden kann die sie
überlegen uns wie könnte es dann auch
digitalisierung in meine und auch in
neue form von wissen und natürlich
bestimmen das hat luciano florida getan
das ist sicherlich ein problem das wir
nur so ein bindeglied sind vermittlungs
forscherinnen und forscher immer mehr
bloße daten und meta-daten ja wir sind
auch zu unrecht das müssen wir natürlich
udo kier als das seien also nicht nur
mein zitat stadt formen der isolation zu
schlüsselbegriff eine ethik der
gesundheitsgefährdend ist der vielleicht
und das sehen wir auch schon inszeniert
schritt muss der haustür setzen das ist
agieren häufig werden unsere daten
bereichen zum beispiel wenn sie ein
kritik der neuen medien mit den wurden
wirklich in form einer kaum zu
realität da haben sie bestimmt ganz
ja jetzt hat für reading aber sehr
ein apfel den wir da vor uns haben den
florida ist auch nicht mehr gerecht wird
medien cyberkrieg techno vieli und
buch geschrieben das heißt eine gute
möglichkeiten etwas zu realisieren was
sie in der cloud haben also die sie im
hat an den fehler 4 und information
virtuelle realität von simulationen
noch sein könnte es nicht möglich sein
auch immer erklären wenn wir über eine
flugsimulator sich anschauen wo
lizenz hat mehr gehalt und hier sagt er
daran werden wir ein musikstück was wir
digitalität auch eine philosophie der
von banknoten und die digitalisierung
dadurch auch eine neue form von
eigene vorstellung davon und ich möchte
uns immer überlegen müssen wie sollen
abgegriffen wir hinterlassen spuren und
sogar sucht erregend das sind ja auch
also erst seit ein paar jahren
befördern gehen wird für der realität
einen bereich sind alles grundsätzlicher
sondern ist betrifft eine neue form von
wir anfassen können die eine räumliche
work galaxien es geht also um die neuen
überblickende masse wie wir diese
ein riesenvorteil willkommen das buch
treffen diese folgen auch die ethischen
immer kritisiert vielleicht haben sie
mehr und zwar eben auch durch unsere
entwickelt und auch eine 11 ticks auf
ethik der digitalität reden jetzt
internet haben die sie gar nicht in der
vielleicht auch erst seit der korona
pilotinnen und piloten regelmäßig
oder einer kur klang den mit der natur
digitalität ist mir scheint der der
verantwortung weil er jedenfalls für
wir mit diesen neuen medien umgeht
mit einer fülle neuer und veränderte in
wir vor der digitalisierung noch nicht
das ganze auch so zu tun oder so zu
techno vogel techno viele und
die digitalisierung macht vor nichts
fiktionen illusion streng unterscheidet
sofort sie können es nicht verlieren das
ist letztendlich nur eine weitere
diese spuren werden wieder vom antritt
ausdehnung hat wie kann aber auch mental
ihnen mal ganz kurz eine umfrage eine
realität eben die infos fair ja und
schon mal manfred spitzer gehört der hat
immer die assoziationen die
medien und guttenberg kennen sie alle
information darin wird darauf werden wir
trainieren dann ist es auch gut dass das
informationen handhabbar machen können
vermögen der virtuellen realität das
folgen der infos fähre herausgestellt
sicherlich ist es problematisch wenn wir
krise wirklich weil die diese
erstmal zum begriff der digitalität
halt
hören wenn wir den digitalisierten dann
technologie stellen sich dieselben
wird zu nutzen die aufgegriffen oder
isaac es gibt gar kein recht mehr auf
internetsucht ist das dasselbe einiges
auch wenn wir immer virtueller realität
virtuellen realität ja vielen dank für
konsequenz oder eine radikalisierung
sein unsere gedanken sind jetzt nicht
buch und sie können es auch nicht
konnten und hier ist jetzt ganz wichtig
der aktions möglichkeit und sozial form
ihrem pc direkt haben sind die sie nur
glaube ich jedenfalls und wird auch
auch in diesem seminar noch genauer
dem erfinder ob er wirklich der erfinder
jetzt hier einige sehr provokativen
nicht die realität ist weil da kann man
entwicklung der digitalisierung auch
virtualisieren
nicht repräsentative umfrage
scheint mir bei florian auch ein
felix stalder ich hatte dazu einen
für ihn spricht davon dass wir in der
wie wir sie teilen können wie wir sie
zeichnen wir dann auf und am ende können
fragen was kommt als nächstes
die neuen medien nur eine nette
irgendwie zerstören oder beschädigen
nicht wissen weil wir prinzipiell alles
das heißt in den begriff der virtualität
bisschen zu kurz zu kommen durch diese
wenn wir dinge posten im internet dann
dieses phänomens der virtuellen realität
vorangetrieben hat da sehen wir dass das
demonstrieren von teilnehmerinnen und
darauf beziehen müssen virtuelle
eingehen ich hatte schon gesagt ich
es ist die frage manches wagen hoch
der begriff der neuen medien und
über internetzugang erreichen können das
mehr räumlich irgendwie strukturiert
dann halt auch mal gerne abstürzen und
titel auch formuliert von seinen büchern
immer weniger halt machen falls sie noch
die aufmerksamkeit und ich bin jetzt
spielerei nutzt eine spielhölle und das
einher hier darf man noch mal an felix
mit anderen informationen auf
info sphäre vor allem wegen der digital
gefahr
auszug herumgeschickt an sie die er
wir ihn zu legen in lautern 1 also
also wohl die die leute unter uns die
ausschließliche aber sehr ergiebige
wissen können und drittens verstärkt
kommt ganz zentral der begriff der
wenn ihnen der kaffee drüber läuft es
beziehen sich andere darauf wir hatten
lernen was da so passieren könnte gut
halt macht ist es nur eine frage der
glaube auch dass der informations
gespannt auf die diskussion
stalder begriff der gemeinschaftlichkeit
individuelle persönliche weise neu eine
vielleicht in unserem kopf aber wo genau
die neuen medien wie computer wie
realität ist lebensweltlich consult
was wird zum beispiel eben schon bei
sind solche virtuellen produkte die
pokern vom beweglichen lettern den gab
digitale immer weniger zu einem bloßen
teilnehmern einer vergangenen
inklusive
durchaus auch diskreter quantifiziert
dieser autor sagt ziel dieses buches ist
spricht von einer kultur der digitalität
sind eine pseudo welt flüchten auf der
einmal die digitale demenz wie wir uns
geht alles nicht der kaffee kann die
zeit bis sie auch andere bereiche
begriff nicht ausreicht um diese
veranstaltung was die zum thema
also sie folgen einer anderen räumlichen
geld 10 die digitalisierung
schon gesehen mit like und so weiter mit
möglichkeit hinein aber auch im sinne
sich der effekt der beiden angeführten
natürlich eine ganz neue form von
konzentration auf die information weit
erinnern dass virtuelle wird auf diese
der technik freundlich gesinnt sind
reibungslos interagieren warum
es auch schon davor jedenfalls
beziehung setzen kann wie wir kurz mit
dass es nicht realität ist da können wir
zwerge computer laufen aber damit geht
wirksam objektiv anders als endlose
internet unter die erlauben es uns
bereich wird unserer lebenswelt so ein
werden im analogen haben wir immer eher
einbezogen hat das heißt sie betrifft
aber nicht primär die verurteilung das
und unsere kinder um verstand bringen
virtuelle realität zu sagen hatten was
flexibilität ermöglichen weil sie über
der teil also diese gemeinschaftlichkeit
guttenberg hat eine neue galaxie nach
und wie ich schon sagte er sagt seit dem
logik als des physikalischen und das
der freiheit wenn mir etwas möglich ist
technik viel wie auch diejenigen die
phänomene schnell meta informationen
neuartigkeit der digitalisierung bezogen
flexibilisiert nämlich die virtuelle
dieser masse kreativ umgehen kann und
reibungslos sehr gut weil eben durch das
weise nicht nur zu einem resonanzraum
als auch über sprich simulation hat ganz
anderen seite können wir sagen es
simulation und virtuelle realität
gefasst ist nicht ganz spannende these
ein kontinuum also eine kurve und im
virtuelle realität auf eine weise zu
klar abgrenzbare betreibt diese bereich
monieren eines negativen zustand
die cloud nicht mehr angewiesen sind auf
die gesamte lebenswelt das heißt es ist
diese assoziation hatten möchten ein
diesen neuen techniken als kritisch oder
jahr 2000 verbinden sich viele der bis
realität zb des geldes weiter hier ist
virtuelle das virtuelle hat sehr viel
spricht doch jetzt hier nur gegen die
diese dieser inter inter subjektive
internet räumliche und zeitliche
auf unsere lebenswelt zu fassen denn wir
das medium twitter erlaubt uns mit
weit gefasst ist die infos fähre nach
mclaren entworfen nämlich die guttenberg
sozialer es wird zum ort der
verstehen die jetzt nicht mehr nur
enthält momente von simulation fiktion
viel auch mit bildung zu tun mit
ja durchaus eine existenzielle frage
bestimmte physischen gegebenheiten sind
digitalen wird die kurve mehr oder
der digitalisierung der trinkt immer
zucker abwehren
dahin voneinander unabhängigen
ähnlichkeit mit dem mentalen weil es
galaxie wo eben die schrift eine ganz
distanzen eigentlich wegfallen ich kann
digitalisierung ein falscher medien gibt
florida ein begriff der sich anonym mit
zusammenhang internet der wird noch viel
dieser massen information auf eine neue
schein oder trug ist es gibt ja neues
haben auf der einen seite daten und
jetzt nicht so zu verstehen im sinne
experiment was wir uns vielleicht in der
entgegengesetzt sind die stellen sich
weniger nicht mehr genau hinschauen zu
warum weil wir durch die virtualisierung
eigentlich überall jederzeit dieses
entwicklungen verstärken und verändert
mehr weiter vor der vergrößert sich
intensiver
informationen durch die digitale wir
weise umzugehen natürlich auch diese
in sekundenbruchteilen eine nachricht an
auch nicht ganz physisch ist nicht ganz
neue bedeutung erlangte durch den tod
sagte stahl und zum schluss ein dritter
ja neue ideen realisieren kann ganz neue
dass sie unbedingt eine bedrohung ist
dieselbe frage was kommt als nächstes
gemacht die digitalisierung mit anderen
sich und bilden nun eine neue kulturelle
buch das handbuch virtuelle virtualität
physikalischen realität zu nicht
etwas diskretem also was ich in
produkt benutzen können dass das ist
reduziert werden kann natürlich können
worten die trinkt in alle möglichen
sie kann auch zu einer bedrohung werden
information zu bewerten also ein like
einheiten zerlegen lässt dieser übergang
meine brieffreundin in den usa schicken
getrauen wird und die illusion ist
konstellation also wir sehen wir das ist
eigenschaften und co die landschaft ist
möglichkeiten erschließen können die
darin beschreiben die autoren ziemlich
wir sagen dass in thale ins tor es sind
und da müssen wir uns ausdrücken
vom analogen zum digitalen das ist die
mehr brieffreundin trifft gar nicht mehr
treffend was sich durch die neuen medien
digitalisierung ist die technische
technologische sei dies das ist ganz
wichtig auf der anderen seite können wir
unterscheiden zwischen der
digitalisierung im gegensatz zur
digitalität das wäre die philosophische
seite also wir betrachten aus
philosophischer seite nicht nur diesen
übergang vom analogen zum digitalen
sondern wir betrachten den übergang von
dem technischen zum kulturellen oder zum
lebensweltlich und das ist der fokus
unseres seminars wir sind ja denkt nur
sehr wenige informatikerin informatiker
sicherlich haben wir
experten dieser art unter uns was unser
interessiert ist was passiert wenn die
digitalisierung also wenn dieser
technische vollzug bereits erfolgt ist
was passiert wenn die digitalisierung
einzug hält in unsere lebenswelt und war
eigentlich nichts mehr halt macht was
passiert dann und das ist eine frage die
aus der differenz von analog und digital
so nicht geklärt werden kann sondern
unsere fahrer gesetzt bereits den
erfolgreichen oder vielleicht auch nicht
erfolgreichen übergang von analog zu
digital voraus und fragt auf dieser
basis der erfolgten digitalisierung was
passiert wenn sie die digitalisierung
einfach alle bereiche unserer lebenswelt
zunehmend betrifft transformiert disrupt
destruktiv behandelt wie auch immer was
passiert okay dann ist spricht eben hier
felix stalder davon dass mit dem ausbau
des internets zu einem allgegenwärtigen
kommunikations und koordinations
infrastruktur um die jahrtausendwende
bisher voneinander unabhängige
kulturelle entwicklung begannen über die
spezifischen kontext ihrer entstehung
hinaus nicht auszubreiten sich
gegenseitig zu beeinflussen zu verstärkt
verstärken und miteinander zu
verschränken aus einem unverbunden
nebeneinander teilweise marginaler als
anständiger praktiken wurde in der folge
neue spezifische kulturelle umwelt wie
vor unseren augen deutliche gestaltung
und mehr und mehr andere kulturelle
konstellation verlagert beziehungsweise
an den rand drängt
[Musik]